[Music]
all right we are in the middle of summer
Bros how's your summer break on wall
good mom
yeah good I'm just not looking forward
to go back to school yeah yes I got a
month left here's our break yeah look at
your skin I know all right so TIFF and
me just got back from Aruba tifus @j
canoes no drinking party it's a Tuesday
she's actually a party today and so
she's filming and I have Isaac all to
myself today
and I am dealing with peely skin Emma
fun yeah it's like playing with dried
glue dry glue oh I got a big piece noise
but yeah TIFF and I just got back from
Aruba and I'm sorry I think you did not
get a chance to coach for Ruffo with us
okay it was just like I get away from me
and TIFF just to have like us time and
and we didn't vlog so if you guys were
looking forward to rubra vlogs that
won't be coming because we really wanted
some us time and a lot of times when we
travel it's always work it's always like
you know vlogging camera stuff and we
don't we didn't want the camera stuff
this time we just wanted us time and go
cuz there's ABC islands right so we the
three of us might go to the B Island so
that might be a log that's right and
Bonaire so we've we fell in love with
the Caribbean but we've never been there
before
the closest thing we've ever experienced
was like Cancun tist been in Tulum and
I've been to there's another one but I
forgot the name of it another big city
in Mexico that people like to go to but
we've never been to the Caribbean and
Aruba was her first encounter with the
islands and the water I have to say was
the most gorgeous water of ever
experienced or seen the sand was like
super powder and it felt like a gigantic
swimming pool in terms of how clean
looking at was yes and oh yeah that's
right it brought you back some sand so
sad look they got me can you smell it
you can see it from the bottom yeah we
see from the bottom there we go
looks very powdery mm-hmm I'm peeling
recovering from being burnt up probably
wise not to go swimming and be in the
Sun but we're all geared up to go
swimming okay yeah you ready yep all
right let's go
get these cats out so get out all right
cats like to poop on the bed for some
reason it's like they think they're
leaving us a gift when we're gone and so
it's a rule now to keep them out of the
bedroom yeah and oh yeah and this is
their doing - every morning they like to
claw at the entrance
that's right cats doing so it's like
they miss us they want to be with us I'm
sorry but sometimes you guys are just
really active that night yeah I hear him
like he's loving Meow's yeah last night
he knows heartbroken oh yeah yeah
I keep me out like heartbroken he was
singing the blues to you who's meowing
the blues oh I see oh I think why can't
I be in the room
[Music]
[Music]
right now I know they'll actually
feeling okay today I was like trying to
like really oh you're lucky cuz you're
fair you can wear makeup I mean I guess
a guy can wear makeup to tell them how
much you like the Roomba is like the
most beautiful feature blogs don't
respect any aruba talk anymore from here
on out no more no more no more
you said no more uber talk but any
attempts or whether or not I like to
remake the room suck would you like a
robot
yeah maybe I even have it off my new
wallpaper blog you'll every galaxy it's
moving its video for now we're eating
binamis food cuz I think like spiky I
think you as enemies man another
lifetime with anything so awesome that I
got tired so I go
[Music]
cuz you made me like I'm just a Chinese
kid that grew up in Texas and had a lot
of enemies friends that's true
and now I like Mexican food better oh so
you're saying after we there's gonna be
another Mexican grow to know you like it
well done sometimes I get so like it
looks so delicious when it's like pink
like that I just eat it when it's like
super red you know a song is playing in
my head and I watched I'd like to like
enjoy his
[Music]
so one of my favorite things we've
started doing this summer Isaac is we
started playing Halo together Halo came
out when I was the first taillow
first-generation Xbox came out I think
when I was 10 or 11 so roughly Isaac's
age and I just remember having so much
fun with Halo and that was roughly at
the time when I that was like the last
video craze I went through and then I
kind of stopped playing video games
altogether and I haven't really gamed
for the past 15 years or so we finally
convinced TIFF that halo wasn't although
has mature rating it's not really that
bad it's an older game especially the
first one and you know the graphics were
older and even with the they they they
redid the first game actually with
better graphics now and it's it's still
fake right sweetheart wink I feel like
other games are way better like the
graphics oh yeah they came out in 2015
yeah I'm better than the halo that came
out right now true true except really
look for that's the best one so we we
convinced if that hey halos you know
although it has an M rating it's candy
for teens and you know we did the whole
look up on the internet and a lot of
other parents also agreed that hey this
is a pastime for me growing up and I can
actually play this with my six-year-old
son lots of comments like that and so
were like yeah it wasn't that bad yeah
you're 11 it's been great reliving my
own childhood
along with Isaac then you are a halo
fanatic now
[Music]
how do you know this stuff do you
recognize these math so fast he's
killing me every single round now I
can't I can't get a win on Isaac Isaac
is so good now hey do you want to start
recording our gameplay yeah sure we make
halo gameplay videos on this channel
what do you think Isaac yeah you want to
do it write in the comments below let us
know if we think if you think that's a
great idea
cuz it's pretty fun playing Halo with
Isaac and that thing I'd be fun to
record ourselves and re-watch it where
are you going I'm going to the spa with
the girls we're going to Korean ginger
bum spa make it time so we're gonna all
get naked
bye I'm sorry it's gonna be boys night
in I was like I was like boys night out
we're not going anywhere
boys night and we're about to play some
halo you know what I would love for you
guys to do during your boys night in
what can you fold all these clean towels
are on the bed yes thank you goodbye
girls where's my kiss girls line up boy
am i raising a misogynist hey what is
that
what do you mean you can explain I gotta
go okay love you have a real dough okay
the plane to him what that means the
massage is raising a boy I love you have
a good time too I say be saved love you
a misogynist is oh they're so cute / -
zoomed in hmm those are my cats
[Music]
[Music]